thomas thiel ist im leben immer
vorangegangen beruflich und privat
biscuit 19 ihn ausgebremst hat
ich habe heute weniger schmerzen ich bin
heute wache aber man ist zuschauer
man ist zuschauer im eigenen leben
tägliches training für brigitte stanke
die selbstständige radiologen hätte nie
gedacht dass sie noch so lange mit den
folgen ihrer erkrankung kämpfen muss
arbeitsfähig ist sie noch nicht fassen
dass ich mein doch sehr ausgeprägtes
fotografisches gedächtnis also zum ganz
großen teil verloren habe jeder schritt
noch immer ein kraftakt acht wochen lag
wolfgang schäfer im künstlichen koma
der weg zurück ins leben mühsam und fast
hätte er es nicht geschafft also zweimal
angerufen zu werden
das ist zu ende geht ist schon heftig
corona hat diese drei schwer getroffen
mit den folgen kämpfen sie noch immer
[Musik]
zunächst ist man erst mal froh dass man
hier sein darf dass man der tochter
überhaupt zu gucken
dass man in einem schönen umfeld
versucht gesund zu werden
[Musik]
aber man ist zuschauer man als zuschauer
im eigenen leben und das ist echt so
schwierig weil man einen allen sachen
einfach aus der perspektive teilnimmt
die man sonst nicht hätte sonst war man
aktiv mit dabei
grüße und genesungswünsche aus der zeit
in der thomas thielen lange im
krankenhaus lag
nach seinem schweren cupid 19 verlauf
ist der 41-jährige jetzt wieder zu hause
thomas vielen gilt als wieder genesen
doch gesund ist dann noch lange nicht er
kämpft mit folgeerkrankungen wie viele
andere post cupid patientinnen und
patienten auch im internet tauschen sie
erfahrungen aus den von ärzten fühlen
sich viele allein gelassen
die ärzte kennen unsere erkrankung noch
nicht um die folgen und viele von den
gruppenmitgliedern aber ich habe es auch
man fühlt sich nicht ernst genommen weil
man halt jetzt gerade in der
schulmedizin noch keine antworten hat
das was den postkunden patienten gut tut
muss von posco witt patienten erst an
den arzt getragen werden und der arzt
muss dann auch noch so gut sein um zu
sagen das hört sich gut an dass das gebe
ich als rezept weiter
schmerzmittel sind teil des alltags
geworden an arbeit ist nicht zu denken
vor seiner co wird erkrankung war thomas
thelen der fels in der brandung für die
ganze familie
auch seine schwiegereltern wohnen in dem
großen haus in leverkusen ein
wohnkonzept für das sich die familie
ganz bewusst entschieden hatte doch ihr
glück stand auf der kippe
vieles hing und hängt noch immer an
thomas thiel
er ist der hauptverdiener der familie
ich habe auch verdammt viele ängste am
anfang ganz verlieren alles zu verlieren
was von sie aufgebaut haben hängt er so
vieth rande
ich verdränge vieles einfach
wenn man manchmal so sieht das will man
alles ganz wahrhaben was sie nicht einen
einsamen dunklen raum gehen einfach
türen zu machen das alles nicht sehen
starke schmerzen und
konzentrationsprobleme plagen den
unternehmer kraft in dieser schweren
zeit tankte vor allem bei ehefrau verena
und tochter hannah kurze stippvisite in
betrieb thomas thielen liebt seinen job
das unternehmen vermietet und verkauft
spezialkran tommy wie sie ihn hier
nennen ist ehrgeizig das sagt davon sich
selbst seit monaten hat er seine
kolleginnen und kollegen nicht mehr
gesehen
fühlt sich fremd an hört sich verrückt
für komplette fremden und auch so weit
weg noch der job generell was bedeutet
ihnen ihre arbeit
neben der familie alles das ist mein
hobby das ist mein leben die mitarbeiter
sind meine freunde für mich für die
verantwortlich das ist viel
es ist etwas großes zu empfehlen das ist
wahnsinn das ist wirklich november 2009
10 super stichwahl nicht wie lange tommy
dem unternehmen noch fehlen wird ist
ungewiss
seine geschäftspartnerin und sein
geschäftspartner versuchen tommys
abwesenheit zu kompensieren
aber da gibt es noch ein anderes problem
auf kurz oder lang dieses unternehmen
als nachfolger übernehmen soll
das ist kein geheimnis und das ist
natürlich für mich momentan sehr hart
weil ich natürlich auch damit geplant
habe und darüber nachdenken welche
zeitabläufe haben wir in den nächsten
jahren
wir sind ja nicht nur unternehmer alle
drei sondern wir sind ja freunde und
dann ist das halt auch noch machen wenn
das sein freund produziert als uns immer
alles ganz weit weg ist und jetzt ist
nicht zum lachen
neben den schmerzen sind kognitive
einschränkungen das größte problem für
thomas zielen
die folge immer wieder verlust des
kurzzeitgedächtnisses viele corona
patienten klagen darüber seine ärzte
versuchen thomas thiele zu helfen doch
sie stoßen immer wieder an grenzen
gegen seine atemwegsbeschwerden helfen
massagen warum aber hat er solche
gedächtnisprobleme dass er manchmal
einfach vergisst die haustür zu
schließen ist dabei noch das geringste
problem
es geht aber auch weiter dass ich halt
ganze situation komplett vergessen also
sprich ich habe mich mit ihm unterhalten
und und treffen dann wieder beim
nächsten klasse gehen und ich weiß nicht
mehr dass ich ihn getroffen habe
eine auf ihn zugeschnittene therapie
gibt es nicht mit der nachsorge von
kogit patienten hat man kaum erfahrung
endeffekt versuche ich mit dem
reha-zentrum mir eine passende post
kurve tria zusammenzubasteln mit vielen
maßnahmen die mir dann halt helfen fit
zu werden
ich hoffe dass ich von der schmerz
medikation dauerhaft so einstellt bin
dass ich sowohl verkehrstauglich bin als
auch berufs fähig und das wird halt ein
prozess an der halt ein bisschen zeit
braucht
wann das sein könnte niemand vermag das
derzeit zu sagen brigitte stammte will
ihr altes leben zurück die ärztin aus
dem kreis friesland hatte sich im august
bei einer freundin mit dem corona virus
angesteckt 15 tage krankenhaus 21 tage
hoch ansteckend fünf lange wochen
quarantäne
[Musik]
das virus hatte ihren körper voll im
griff
[Musik]
die koordination macht mir extrem
problem heute luft komme ich langsam
klar dass es besser geworden aber
natürlich wissen auch noch viel luft
nach oben
die rehaklinik heiligendamm in
mecklenburg vorpommern hat sich auf post
cupid 19 patienten spezialisiert
was mussten sie alle hier gelten laut
statistik als genesen sind aber längst
noch nicht arbeitsfähig sowie brigitte
stand gab die selbständige radiologin
lag nach der quarantäne wochenlang
kraftlos auf dem sofa und sorgte sich
immer mehr ob sie jemals wieder in ihren
job arbeiten könne
das war ganz furchtbar also ich habe
mich gar nicht wiedererkannt ich es geht
jetzt noch so dass man wirklich unten
ist ich hab' ich habe gedacht dass das
kann alles gar nicht wahr sein ich habe
mich gefühlt 14 prozent und vor allen
dingen weil einem auch ja keiner sagt
wie lange die ganze geschichte dauert
wenn man sonst irgendwie den arm
gebrochen hat dann sagt man gut sechs
wochen bis man raus und dann fängt man
wieder an zu arbeiten dann ist alles
wieder gut
und das war eben in der situation
überhaupt nicht abzusehen
das alles hat mich wirklich extrem
runtergezogen und ich habe wirklich viel
geweint und war am boden zerstört
in ihrem heimatort findet sie keine
hilfe
mit den folgen einer cupid 19 erkrankung
kennen sich die ansässigen ärzte nicht
aus es fehlt an erfahrungswerten
schließlich hört brigitte stammte von
der klinik in heiligendamm
hier hofft sie wieder fit zu werden
das ganze versuchen sie jetzt auch mal
rückwärts die knie immer noch nach außen
drehen einfach die richtung wechseln
schultert auch nach hinten drehen
dabei versuchen sie mal leichte sprünge
zu machen
leichte sprünge und die hände kreisen
dabei zurück doch die sonst so
sportliche frau gelangt immer wieder
schnell an ihre grenzen
[Musik]
das übervolle komplett muss ich die
augen zumachen oder auf einen sport
gucken und sich wieder zu langsam runter
kommen früher bin ich natürlich
geschockt ich habe viel im body styling
gemacht ich jazz dance gemacht und also
gerade so was wie koordination ist für
mich überhaupt kein thema gewesen und
jetzt geht das alles nicht und was macht
einen schon ganz schön fertig inwiefern
das denken sie sich ja ich habe einfach
angst dass das nicht wieder kommt dass
ich in mein altes leben nicht mehr so
zurück kann fängt beim einkaufen an ich
kann nicht in ein geschäft gehen
ich bin seit meiner erkrankung wenn ich
im oktober einmal
in einem supermarkt gewesen wollte
einfach mal ein bisschen einkaufen das
ging gar nicht ich bin da fast
zusammengebrochen musste den
einkaufswagen als rollator und benutzen
um zur kasse zu kommen weil mich diese
ganze information diese diese diese
vielen farben und dieses angebot
vergleichen von irgend welchen preisen
das war gar nicht möglich sagt mich so
überfordert so dass sich daneben auch
körperlich darauf reagiere genau wie
eben hier auch ergotherapie bei
chefärztin jördis frommhold noch im
krankenhaus merkt brigitte stanke dass
sie das mathe ass plötzlich nicht mehr
kopfrechnen kann auch bücher lesen oder
sogar einfache kurze texte erfassen geht
plötzlich nicht mehr
eine scheinbar leichte aufgabe ich
brauche die maus wirklich jeder
einzelnen ziffern mit der anderen
vergleichen
die fahren dabei die farben sind wir
wirklich zum einen kann ich das kaum
fassen dass ich doch sehr ausgeprägtes
fotografisches gedächtnis also zum ganz
großen teil verloren habe tatsächlich
sehen wir jetzt bei vielen patienten
zunehmend wirklich so sehr
einschränkende kognitive defizite die ja
schon fast in der richtung ja
demenzielle geschehen anmuten lassen und
wir haben letztendlich keine erklärung
dafür woran ist denn letztendlich liegt
bei längst nicht allen patienten sind
die symptome so stark wie bei guitar
stand doch wer davon betroffen ist
reagiert meist verängstigt und stark
verunsichert bilder analysieren für die
radiologin war das bisher routine
die differenzierung gelingt nicht und
das macht natürlich komplett im loch
versenken
sie ahnt es wird dauern bis sie wieder
die ist die sie vor der kogit 19
erkrankung war vielleicht noch wochen
oder gar monate auf jeden fall braucht
sie auch nach ende der reha noch
fachliche betreuung doch die wird nur
selten angeboten
das liegt nicht nur daran dass die
strukturen noch nicht da sind sondern
auch dass die schule wurde die
aufklärung einfach noch nicht so weit
fortgeschritten ist also ich habe
rückmeldungen von einigen patienten die
bereits jetzt auch schon entlassen sind
wieder bei uns die auch berichten dass
es ambulant letztendlich nicht wirklich
weitergeht weil sich kaum jemand mit
diesem bereich auskennt und das ist
glaube ich ein ganz ganz großes manko
wir als gesellschaft
noch dran arbeiten müssen brigitte stand
ge will sich nicht unterkriegen lassen
körperlich und mental hat sie während
der reha gute fortschritte gemacht ich
habe hier wieder mut gefasst
wenn ich nach hause komme brauche ich
aber sicherlich noch adäquate hilfen
damit ich wieder so werde wie ich mir
das vorstelle und was ja mein ziel ist
es geht nur sehr langsam voran und es
sind kleinste schritte mit denen sich
wolfgang schäfer wieder zurück ins leben
kämpft aber er ist wieder zu hause in
seinem eigenen garten
für den 54-jährigen ist das der
wichtigste schritt auf seinem weg der
genesung der ruhephase oder die
aufbauphase beginnt in der familie und
zu hause
die könnte ich die können sie in dem
krankenhaus nicht darstellen die reha ja
alles gut und schön aber sie sind in dem
krankenhaus sie sind für sich alleine
die familie ist nicht um sicherung und
entsprechend das war schon was aus also
hier hat es eigentlich richtig
angefangen wo ich mich wieder aufbauen
wolfgang schäfer im juni in einer
rehaklinik in bad lippspringe wird er
nach drei monaten krankenhausaufenthalt
wieder fit gemacht
er ist abgemagert sein körper massiv
geschwächt
die narben sind noch deutlich sichtbar
dort wo die schläuche in seinem körper
stecken ohne hilfe kann wolfgang schäfer
eigentlich nichts mehr machen jeder
schritt raubt ihm den atem
ein harter kampf zurück ins leben den
der 54 jährige beinahe verloren hätte es
ist der 17
märz der tag den wolfgang schäfer nie
wieder vergessen wird
seit tagen fühlt er sich schlapp sein
hausarzt vermutet eine bronchitis
dann verlässt ihn seine erinnerung
wolfgang schäfer kippt plötzlich um acht
wochen liegt er im künstlichen koma
zweimal muss er in dieser zeit
wiederbelebt werden die familie band um
den ehemann den vater also zweimal
angerufen zu werden
dass es zu ende geht ist schon heftig
erst gab sie die momente in denen sich
wolfgang schäfer gefragt hatte was er
überhaupt in zukunft noch fähig sein
würde
[Musik]
die musik hatte er immer geliebt war als
keyboarder in einer band auf tour sogar
im ausland
ich frage mich immer an erster stelle
trotzdem ist die musik für mich ein
leben so ich habe ganz zu anfang gesagt
ich glaube das war es mit der musik aber
mittlerweile ist der drang zu muss ich
wieder da und das schöne ist es ist
sogar eine physische übung für mich weil
ich die fingerfertigkeit dadurch wieder
einüben kann und letztendlich eine
bewegungstherapie dabei habe sogar alles
ist für den 54 jährigen zum training
geworden selbst die spülmaschine
auszuräumen sich bücken hände und beine
benutzen alles muss koordiniert werden
und alles verlangt die volle
konzentration
das hat corona mit wolfgang schäfer
gemacht dass es menschen gibt die die
krankheit leugnen macht ihn wütend ich
habe verständnis dafür wenn jemand sagt
ich kenne keinen meinem umfeld der so
was hatte das dass man sich dass da
nicht richtig vorstellen kann ist alles
okay aber dass man es nicht glauben kann
und versucht zu leugnen
das ist das ist eine sache die ich mir
überhaupt nicht vorstellen kann weil
wenn jeder so denkt werden wir niemals
auf einen nenner kommen
also ich kann die leute nicht verstehen
ich kriege den hals zweimal in der woche
geht wolfgang schäfer zur physiotherapie
nach seinem langen krankenhausaufenthalt
ist eigentlich sein ganzer körper eine
einzige baustelle
weil ich ziemlich gut ja dass bewegung
die einschränkungen sind immer noch da
an den beinen durch die fuß heber aber
ich habe hier in der schulter eben noch
diese bewegungseinschränkungen er
wenn ich aber liege also ganz normale
bett liege kann ich bei der armen kopf
nehmen und sie haben auch hände zusammen
dann über dem kopf dann funktioniert das
alles das blockiert sich nur um stehen
wie viele andere patienten leidet auch
wolfgang schäfer gleich an mehreren
folge erkrankungen
mediziner sprechen von post kowitz
syndrom
während man bei der akutbehandlung von
corona patientinnen fortschritte machen
konnte ist man bei der nachsorge noch
ganz am anfang
genauso wichtig ist es für die patienten
die diese erkrankung jetzt überstanden
habe und an dem post kurve syndrom
leiden geeignete frührehabilitation
programme zu erstellen auch geeignete
nachsorge im ambulanten bereich zu
erstellenden da fehlt es an jeder
struktur mehr als acht monate sind
vergangen seit ihn die krankheit aus
seinem alten leben gerissen hat ein
halbes jahr hat wolfgang schäfer fast
ausschließlich im bett gelegen muskeln
und nerven verkümmert und geschädigt die
fortschritte seien sie das letzte mal
getroffen haben
klar auf jeden fall die stabilität kommt
die gleichgewichtsprobleme werden
weniger die sind aber immer noch da aber
stabilisiert sich langsam alles aber es
dauert wirklich das hätte ich nicht
gedacht dass das so langwierig ist aber
es ist so ich habe manchmal durchhänger
da hilft die familie wieder hochzukommen
nach dem motto nützt nichts du musst
dadurch aber ich bin gott sei dank eine
kämpfernatur die sich ein ziel setzt und
dieses ziel auch erreichen möchte
ich habe für den 50 jahre darauf
hingearbeitet so zu sein jetzt möchte
ich auch wieder so werden womit 19 hat
sein leben verändert und das von vielen
anderen auch wenn es eine chance gibt
dass sich so manches wieder normalisiert
dieser einschnitt in ihr leben wird
spuren hinterlassen